hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming through to another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so
we're going to talk about in this video
is what exactly is Rolle's Theorem and
how to use it so let's get right into
the definition of a Rolle's Theorem and
then we'll go into some examples so
first things first what is Rolle's
Theorem well it tells us here let F be
continuous so let F be a function that's
continuous on the closed interval A to B
okay and differentiable on the open
interval A to B okay so not including
the two endpoints and if F of a equals F
of B then there is at least one number C
in this interval a B such that F prime
of C equals zero okay let's see if we
can kind of just unpack that real
quickly here basically when it says that
it's continuous that means that there's
no break in the graph so for example if
we were graphing this okay and let's
just say that the graph looks something
like this okay I'll just make it like
that okay and let's just say that this
is a a over here and let's say this is a
B over here and you can see that you
know it's continuous there's no breaks
in the graph I'm not picking up my
pencil or my pen okay differentiable
means that you know at any point along
this curve okay we can find the slope we
can take the derivative there's no
corners there's no costs nothing like
that it's smooth we can take the
derivative okay and then the last part
says that if the Y value so whenever you
see f of X that's really saying the Y
value or the output at a if that equals
the Y value at B okay then there has to
be at least one number in between a and
B such that the derivative equals zero
meaning that the slope of the tangent
line is horizontal so I'm going to
adjust my location of B right here let's
make B right here okay and what you can
see is that a and B okay they have the
same y value see how they're at the same
height okay like that and
so what that means is that somewhere in
between a and B the derivative okay
meaning the slope of the tangent line
has to be 0 and you can see that would
occur somewhere right about here okay
there would be your tangent line right
like so and it's going to have a slope
of 0 now it can occur at more than one
point so say for example if the graph
was looking more like this okay then
there could be multiple points okay in
between a and B where the slope of the
tangent line is 0 okay but basically the
way I think about it just real briefly
is that you know if they have the same y
value of at a and B you have a couple
options one it could just be like a
horizontal line okay or you can think of
the graph is going to go up at some
point but then it has to come back down
right to get to that same height or that
same y-value or the graph could go down
and then come back up again to reach
that same y-value so because it has to
reach that same y-value at both the
endpoints the graph has to basically
bend or turn somewhere in between those
two points and that's what allows us to
find the point where the tangent line is
going to be horizontal it's like a
roller coaster going up and they're
coming back down you reach that same
height so somewhere in between there
you're going to be horizontal okay so
let's look at some examples so example
number one we've got a function here f
of x equals x squared minus 2x plus 1
and the interval that they're giving us
is negative 1 2 3 so first thing we want
to test okay is to see if rolls theorem
applies okay and we know that this is a
polynomial so we know that it's
continuous there's no breaks in it and
we know that it's smooth meaning that we
can take the derivative anywhere along
this curve okay even in between negative
1 and 3 the next thing that we want to
test is that what does the value of F of
negative 1 equal and what does the value
of F of 3 equal well you can see if we
put negative 1 in for X we get negative
1 squared minus 2 times negative 1 plus
1 okay this is 1 plus 2 okay plus 1
which is 4
and if we put three in what do we get
three squared minus two times three plus
one that's nine minus six which is three
plus one equals four so what you can see
is we have negative one four and we have
three comma four and you can see that
they have the same y-value okay so what
that means is that somewhere in between
negative one and three the slope of the
tangent line must be equal to zero and
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to take the derivative so f prime
of x equals 2x minus two we're going to
set that equal to zero okay add two to
both sides and then divide by two and
you can see that that value is going to
be when x equals one one of course is in
between negative 1 and positive 3 and
the slope of the tangent line at that
point is going to be 0 it's going to be
horizontal if you want to graph this
just to understand it a little bit
better this is actually a parabola
that's been shifted right one so it
looks something like this okay and so
over here we have negative 1/4 that's
this point and we have 3/4 that's this
point you can see that they're at the
same height and in between negative 1
and 3 there's a point in this case it's
at positive 1 where the horizontal you
know the tangent line is horizontal at
zero now it happens to be right you know
in between right in the middle at the
midpoint that's not always the case I
just did this as a simple example just
so I can show you the graph and just
kind of show you how it works but again
you want to make sure that it satisfies
all these conditions continuous
differentiable and that the the Y values
at both of the endpoints are the same
and then that apply rolls theorem
applies meaning the in between those two
endpoints the tangent line has to be
horizontal so let's look at another
example number two here they give us a
function x squared minus 4 all divided
by X okay and we're looking at the
interval negative 2 to 2 before we can
jump into rolls theorem we have to see
if it applies so we have to look at is
it continuous is it differentiable and
are the Y values at the two end points
the same well okay first of all we
notice this denominator and we know the
denominator can equal zero because if it
equals zero this is going to be
find in this particular graph we're
going to have a horizontal I'm sorry a
vertical asymptote okay at x equals zero
so that means that X cannot equal zero
zero is in between negative two and two
so this graph is not continuous on this
interval which means that roles theorem
does not apply so we we can't proceed
and find out where those points are
going to be because they don't
necessarily exist so roles theorem
doesn't apply in this case because it's
not continuous so a couple examples here
about how to work with Rolle's Theorem
I'll have another video talking about
the mean value theorem which is like an
extension okay of Rolle's Theorem and
we'll get into that in the next video so
subscribe to the channel check out some
of my other videos and I look forward to
helping you in the next video